a possible Feud connections to Big names
like Snoop Dogg and now one man who
claims he's been wrongfully convicted
it's all part of a criminal case that
just took a turn only the eight news now
investigators have been following the
Battle brewing in court Vanessa Murphy
has been speaking with the man at the
center of it all
Denise and Brian rapper Mac Minister
insists he's an innocent man he's been
telling me this during phone calls from
prison and he's alleging this in court
but prosecutors argue there are too many
connections between Mac Minister and
three people who wound up dead
Andre Dao also known as Mack Minister
was an up-and-coming West Coast rapper
in the early 2000s but that came to a
halt
Dow was convicted in 2008 for a double
murder in Las Vegas in 2005. the victims
Kansas City rappers Anthony Watkins
known as fat tone and Jermaine Atkins
known as Cowboy
how did they end up murdered in your
girlfriend's car
as attorney Robert DeMarco argues for
Dow's Freedom the eight news now
investigators have been following
closely one major development this
witness who testified against Dao now
says he lied it's been under conscience
and you deeply regret making the false
testimony in statements against Mr doubt
correct correct Mr Latif grave please a
former San Francisco prosecutor who knew
Dao growing up heard him proclaiming his
innocence on a podcast and decided to
look into the case do you believe he's
100 innocent no based on this evidence I
do Latif gray says he uncovered
information about witness Antoine Mouton
a convicted pimp with a lengthy criminal
history records show when he claims he
was in Las Vegas and dalmade
incriminating statements to him he was
actually in custody in Georgia do you
believe that the police and the
prosecutors had all of this information
and hit it or what are you saying they
definitely have sometimes
Clark County chief Deputy district
attorney Mark digiacomo mentioned a date
during Dow's murder trial in reference
to that supposed conversation between
Dao and Mouton in Las Vegas but again
Mouton was locked up in Georgia to
Giacomo now on the stand himself
admitting to what he calls a mistake if
you said December 5th in the deposition
correct and I should have said December
05. still he continues to defend the
murder conviction I have the phone
records in the 911
in 2004 Bay Area rapper Mac Dre was
killed in Kansas City there were rumors
which police said were false that fat
tone did it Dow claims he didn't think
so in 2005 he invited fat tone to Las
Vegas to meet Snoop Dogg Dao is seen
leaving a casino with fat tone and
cowboy he claims they went their
separate ways
the bodies of fat tone and cowboy found
near a construction site a car which
prosecutors argue was connected to the
scene found torched in California two
days later police also pointed to Dow's
link to his co-defendant Jason Mathis
and a woman who was found murdered in
California later that year before Dell
was in custody you cannot point to any
specific evidence that points to Mr Dao
committing the murder
Mitch Larson in California correct well
I think that if I were to try into this
courtroom like the victim every day of
the week Dow was on America's Most
Wanted and then arrested if he didn't
pull the trigger he's just as guilty as
the person I did put you Lamont Williams
also known as Marlo boss is fat Tone's
cousin he's most definitely behind it so
yes most definitely I said a thousand
times I see it in his face a thousand
times after hearing from both sides this
is totally a travesty objective a judge
will decide whether Dow deserves freedom
prosecutors argue key witness Antoine
Mouton may have felt pressured to
recount his story but Mouton and his
father who also testified claimed he
just wanted to do the right thing that
decision from the judge could come any
day now